love
and accept yourself
first and foremost
you are the infinite expressing itself
you are source you are god you
are dao you are brahmana you are that
tatvam asi i and my father are one
you are it this is why
incredible figures in our cultural
history
like mr rogers were so adamant about
that recognition even in the youngest
of youth in childhood recognize
that you are the jigsaw
piece that always fits
perfectly you're simultaneously
absolute infinite perfection
while you're also the beautiful process
of turning inward and recognizing
awareness as
god and also being the unique
expression of that infinite artistically
contributing a gift
to the creation design
so love and accept yourself first
and foremost exactly precisely
beautifully as you are
you're already so beautiful
love and accept yourself first and
foremost
and then second we quiet our mind
this is what buddha taught
stop the cravings and the aversions stop
the monkey mind like
patanjali also taught yogas
chitta fritti nirodha yoga or
union with god with the absolute
is simply the quieting of the
fluctuations of
mind
and we use our breath which is the tool
that's always present with
us
to create the juxtaposition
for us to recognize that we are not the
cloud
of thought of emotion the feeling the
sensation
the experience the belief
the object that appearance of form
but we are the sky we are the eternal
shared
awareness where that cloud
transiently appears and then disappears
so you quiet your mind enough to be able
to create that
simple childlike juxtaposition between
the sky
and the clouds the clouds are the mind
and the sky is the eternal shared
awareness it's the observer it's the
witness
it's the very i am-ness just like our
pupil our pupil is that shared
eternal observer among us all
and the iris is the unique coloration
the unique expression
artistically that we are contributing a
gift in this dreamed creation
and so the quieting of the mind creates
like in the parable of the prodigal son
the turn
inward usually
comes with hitting and
breaking point as the contracted energy
of the
finite egoic separate self
seeks peace and happiness externally
can't find it in appearance of form
can't find it in peak experiences
can't find it in substances or in
relationships
so just like in the parable of the
prodigal son it turns inward
just to recognize that the diamond
necklace like rumi said
has always been around our necks the
diamond necklace
is becoming aware of awareness
itself as saint francis of assisi said
that which you are seeking
is the seer itself
just like ramana maharshi said that
god is the seer
so when you become aware of awareness
and how that is eternal and how that is
shared
that's when you've pierced the veilless
veil you've walked through this gateless
gate
you've recognized our true metaphysical
nature at a much
deeper level and now
as sri aurobindo said you've moved
the rock that has covered that well of
honey
and now you bring like rupert spire said
you bring
peace and happiness to
the creation design rather than trying
to extract
peace and happiness from it
and that's what's meant by buddha's
middle way or his middle path
or as ramana maharshi said sahaja
samadhi
or in the tantric tradition you weave
your enlightened realizations into
society
so you recognize that awareness
is shared it's eternal
and then you recognize that even
awareness
itself is dreamed even the agent
of awareness itself
is the very last thorn that we must
pluck out in order for us to recognize
the absolute
so there's the first step of moving from
beyond mind quieting those fluctuations
of the clouds enough to be able to
become aware of awareness itself which
is called god realization
that is shared that is eternal that's
step one
and then the second step is to even
recognize that the
shared eternal agent of awareness itself
is dreamed and
plucking that last thorn out that's
absolute realization that's the second
step
weaving our realizations
into the social fabric
is what brings not only the highest
expression of infinity but also it
maximizes
prosperity for everyone else
these are the very simple steps of the
direct
path to peace and happiness that you
already
are love yourself and accept yourself
you are already it
quiet the mind quiet down those
fluctuations
leverage respiration the breath the tool
that's always with you
to create the juxtaposition create
the pause rather than reacting all the
time
to the stimulus
use the breath to create the pause
and observe and as you do that you will
recognize that
you are the observer you are the witness
you
are the awareness the very sky
that is shared and eternal among us all
and then you recognize that even that
awareness
itself is a dreamed agent
of the absolute
and you weave those realizations into
society and maximize prosperity
maximize metaphysical truth
that's it for the direct path 15. i'll
go ahead
and go over a couple
additional fun insights
that we've been communicating across our
instagram as well things like the
infinite appearing is like the heartbeat
the lub-dub
the lub-dub the
lub-dub
the lub is the outward it's like the
systolic
in the blood pressure
and the dub is the inward
it's like the diastolic in the blood
pressure
the 120 over 80 120
over 80. there's so much additional
pressure
that's made when the heart has to pump
the oxygenated blood
outward throughout the body and there's
so much
less pressure on the dub
on the diastolic when the blood
comes back into the heart
that's deoxygenated that then gets
pumped back out to the lungs
where you have the alveoli that run the
gaseous exchange between o2
and co2 that is happening 20 000
times per day
that many breaths
the same amount of breaths that you take
every single day
can be conceptualized as
the 20 000
infinite creations that are being
created
every single day as we take
our 20 000 breaths there are 20
000 big bangs happening
that's what's meant by the multiverse
that's what's meant by infinity
expressing itself and this just being
one creation design of that
that yin yang of the inhalation
exhalation of the lub dub
is very much like the infinite that
dreams an observer that voyages outward
in divine play
just to return home to its infinite
source
just a voyage again in exploration
again the lub dub
lub
just like the heartbeat just like the
infinite
just like the heartbeat just like the
infinite
across all creation designs
you are one expression in just
this creation design and will
never stop that's what is meant by
eternity
infinitely exploring
and that's the metaphysical truth
and when you become subtle enough to
even feel the one mile
per hour wind where you become subtle
enough to even
feel that dub inside
of your body you melt so deeply into
sensitivity
that ah resumes as your true nature
ah for this breath
all for being able to communicate
to another expression of source across
the interwebs
off for life ah for breath
for water
and being truly grateful
on a moment-to-moment basis
for the hundred billion
people that have lived and died before
us today
that have brought all of these planetary
architectures of prosperity
the very technology that we are using
right now to be able to communicate
across the internet
the very simplicity of opening up the
faucet
and getting running water the very
simplicity of flicking on the light
switch and getting
light
to have a jaw dropping
awe in gratitude
for all that is surrounding the now
for all of the blood
sweat and tears that has went to be able
to provide
you and i with what abundance we have
today
and to recognize ourselves as these next
expressions of infinity
that come through portal in
to maximize the architectures for
prosperity
even more so that the next expressions
of infinity that portal in
just like we're seeing with generation
alpha right now
have even more abundance and even more
creative prosperity
because that's what our ancestors did
and that's what we continue doing and
just like that
generation after generation eternally
we continue expressing ourselves as the
infinite
and one more little
story this one's pretty common it's uh
one that's communicated a lot
the two fish one fish
asks the other fish where is the ocean
and the other fish says you're in it
right now
and the fish asks what is the ocean
and the other fish answers it's our true
being
and the fish asks point me to it
and then the fish answers become
aware of being in it
become aware that this is
the non-dual ocean
this is the ineffable appearance
this is the absolute expressing itself
this is it
why is there an ocean and the fish
responds it's an expression of the
absolute
and the fish asks what is the absolute
and the other fish replies it's this
ocean
and then the fish asks lastly are we the
absolute
and the fish replies the fish are the
absolute as well
you and i and the dreamed creation
design
are the absolute
the observer the witness the awareness
is
the absolute the creation design
the appearance of form and matter is
also the absolute
this is the ocean recognize yourself
as a fish in the ocean
very simply put you're in it right now
you are already the piece
to the puzzle that always fits
you are already that love and accept
yourself
quiet the mind become aware of awareness
recognize that awareness is shared
eternal
and dreamed and weave your realizations
into society
that's it that's the direct path to
peace and happiness
to the diamond that is already around
your neck
that is refracting a unique expression
of the source light
as a contributory gift in this creation
design
and that's the simple analogy of the eye
the pupil
is the shared eternal observer witness
awareness and the iris is the unique
creative expression
the contributory gift that the
individual
brings you are the infinite expressing
itself
as a unique contributory gift
that's why unity sameness
even in the science of dna 99.9
similar across humans and the diversity
the difference between humans dna is 0.1
that's the unique contributory gift
you are a unique expression of the
infinite contributing
a novel beautiful
gift and to maximize
prosperity
and to realize ourselves
as that infinite are the most
important services that we can render
humanity
as ramana maharshi said that god
realization
recognizing yourself as the one infinite
creator is the most important service
you can render humanity
as lao tzu said in the doubter ching
as you recognize the tao
you channel the absolute highest
morality
and ethics in that weaving
of the realizations into the social
fabric
you recognize the other expression of
the infinite is
actually that one infinite creator
it's all coming from the same source
the same infinite the same god the same
brahman the same tao
the same universe the same multiverse
the same universal wave function
the synthesis of science and
spirituality the two greatest driving
forces
that have brought us to where we're at
today
are happening this century at
unprecedented rates
and awakening us all to our metaphysical
truth
i adore you all so much thank you very
much for tuning in
if the video brought you value please
give it a like
also subscribe to the channel if you
haven't
leave a comment below with your thoughts
we'd love to hear from you and share the
video
with others that you know this would
bring value to
join the channel if you would like as a
member get exclusive benefits and
also every single dollar of revenue that
comes in goes directly to
actualizing our fullest projects
and thank you again so much infinite
love
and i hope that this direct path video
has been insightful and has brought you
value
exactly at where you're at in your
journey as an artistic
expression of the infinite
you